[Music]  what a farmtastic day meet otis the  tractor it's time to get going and do  some growing  cockadoodle  otis lives on long hill dairy farm  and he knows when someone has a problem  i can't open the door there's only one  thing to do stop hit the brakes  and help i have to get to the high jump  competition  let's get rolling  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  because having a big heart when he feels  his heart glowing  it makes this farm even better excellent  can i help you get down  thank you otis  this wiggling's got me giggling  [Music]  kevin can you toss me your toe line  just keep holding on celeste let's go  i'm out on this farm we all help each  other that's a 100 genuine farm fact  [Music]  you